[Music]
everybody this is my dad this is my real
dad cheat out we call that in the
business cheap out cheat oh that's too
far out cheat it back in yeah hey there
you go first time from in front of a
camera is that you Wow
second time am I about to hear a story I
don't want to hear your mother and I
back in the 70s Oh actually that's a
long story I won't give it
so dad you're from Boston obviously yeah
it's how the people's automobiles
well you're from Somerville so sorry
right outside of Boston we're all
learning about my dad you're from
Somerville I was bordered familiar and
you have a come you have an oil tank
removal company that's correct
tell the people cuz it's kind of got a
funny name tell the people what it's
called thanks a lot
Seaway
it's called thanks a lot and I've seen
you been on the phone and no matter how
if you're if you're angry or happy it
doesn't matter you'll end the
conversation by saying thanks a lot you
you love good jokes you have a million
jokes that you've you said my whole life
like you called ketchup Irish breweries
Irish gravy
Irish gravy and if a waitress says would
you like some water you always say I
never drink water fish make love in it
people ask me all the time you must be
very proud of your son you must be very
proud and I'd say oh really
what I'm most proud of is that he's just
a wonderful guy cuz it's
a really problem because it's nice to be
important but more important to be nice
[Applause]
[Music]